era da un'ora che trafficavano nuova
casa e mentre ero in salotto e stefano
che è collassato dove stia mandando
sabri me la farò sei contento 7.400 yen
l'entrata affaccio erogati paula quando
ho scoperto quanto costava sia cresciuta
la barba prima non ci aveva visti
celadrin giapponese guardaci ok cip e
ciop periodo ieri
se hai chiudo minchia come ingrassato
tudor e come l'anno scorso al sesso
video lasciate mi piace hanno sgamato
sasha dalla droga catroga medaglie le
cotolette jack sparrow va veramente
caldo ma veramente tanto caldo e viene
da una dimostrazione
questi sono accaldati forte calo c'è un
depliant sulla testa perché ombrello e
gigantesca non avete idea è fichissimo
no lory non farlo lo fa lo fa lo fa ho
deciso mi compro stasta maglia qua
perché fa veramente caldo sono vestito
di nero e quindi girerò con questa
producono rapporti siamo maggiorenni da
un pochettino tutti li metterò sessuali
etero sessuali
ok ragazzi siamo per fare questa cosa
già questa particolarità qui e via di
360 abbiamo appena mangiato
perfetto siamo riusciti a entrare
raccomandandoci con il fast track quindi
stiamo superando tutta la fila normale
ciao ciao sul cazzo rivista in fila
allora non si può riprendere ma ce ne
sbattiamo le palle e salutate statuto
allora si vede tutto stavolta abbiamo
fatto al buio stavolta no bigazzi
moriamo
basta carbonara ragazzino valzania
barbara d'urso
[Applauso]
60 è stato bellissimo
meyer
finito titolo che fa l'azienda e la
figlia che sceglie chi viene e che va
non lo prende me lo prendo lo prendo io
vi capita di artistica in realtà è
un'illusione perché come entri nella
bocca dvd non è che entri dentro c'è
tutta la fila da fare andate a cagare e
anche una pila della madonna 80 minuti
di attesa zia porca vacca siamo messi a
mangiare le agli alieni di toy story il
tema che aveva mangiato metà cervello
potete essere carini voi due con la
maglia dei the story fate voi a posa
sexy per instagram
mamma mia bellissimi fascia come
assassin's creed ti voglio sul tetto
sasha sul tetto solo per mercanti sasha
ho trovato la porta solo per mercanti
mostrato mercanzia entriamo vendiamo
[ __ ] aprite scusate ma con chi e
fisica del fuoco dovrebbe essere
sull'acqua com'è possibile questa cosa
come cazzo fai a vestirsi così male ora
gumy che divertente sto parco non avrò
mai un fitto bene ragazzi almeno
rispetto all'anno scorso stiamo
pranzando in un posto diverso almeno
quello che so credo che sia carne carne
da 5 euro quindi probabilmente il kebab
e oro in confronto facciamo veramente
vomitare abbiamo mangiato veramente 800
che sa cos'è sta roba non lo so ne hanno
credito è veramente morto quando fa
vigeva ai video in mutande
cazzo ragazzi quando fa vigeva uscire il
secondo video di giornata
la mettiamo siccome le cose sono
infinite ovunque siamo andati nell'unica
attrazione dove la coda è di 15 minuti e
perché di 15 minuti la coda ve lo
facciamo vedere subito abbiamo deciso io
sabrina di andare su questo coso mongolo
vieni un attimo per favore devo mettermi
a cintola andrei mai morire la spina per
favore che poi che la coscienza che poi
comoriano bene adesso sì che siamo
sicuri e non moriamo ragazzi stiamo per
morire ve lo dico strangio sta più
adrenalinica della vita attenzione oggi
io o mio dio mio dio mio aiuto aiuto
basta aiuto basta perché sono
terrorizzato aia gira pure miche paura e
cosa saggia
miche pace che cazzo salute ma l'ex pci
ciao letti e belli e la giostra più
scadente che abbia mai visto
mamma mia di tipo vita addosso io allora
che stiamo per fare questa roba che di
base se centri i canestri vinci un
pupazzo questo non c'è quello per niente
all'ultima palla ai 4 kg disponibili
quattro tiri vabbè bravo
la donna tipo
non troppo forte troppo ragione
[Musica]
vaticano
ma ne valeva le valentine
[Applauso]
grazie busto di fulham è tornato
indietro e belliche sono danno così ma
non la tipa me perché a me questi capi e
per te tutor dailly mon ami tudor
cacciabili c'è un vortice voce aveva
messapica rivale figer demonio come
sboccare il tacchino a minchia minchia
pensavo fossi finissimo il sotto
veramente 600 euro di videocamere nel
cesso
anzi nella cascata ma perché continuiamo
a girare basta
ma cos'è questo sono io quando avrò la
patente ragazzi è vero non ridere
siccome sono pigro e non ho voglia di
portare la busta con paperino optato per
questa soluzione
bello ci sono un miliardo di persone in
fila la metro non c'è non vola una mosca
pisi ti senti senti questa uomo questa
urla sono tutti i suoi 1.800 giapponese
tutti zitti madonna italiani di merda
non voglio alzare la voce troppo perché
questa roba e poetica però con questo
sfondo
di gente che sta per prendere la metro
io ho tutto qui il video su disney si
supera vi sia piaciuto come suggerisce
al momento mi piace anche i vari social
convinto tua descrizione
[Musica]
lo pensavo che si staranno tutto da
vedere senza vestiti siete via non ci
vediamo al prossimo meno
[Musica]